Drew, what's going on?
Oh, you know, just-
Tell me everything.
Hanging out, living life.
How's life?
Good?
Yeah, life is good, yes.
Good.
I'm freaking out about your new show,
and I wanna get into-
It's really fun.
Oh, you really go for it.
I'm a dark little lady.
I'm getting Sharon Stone, Basic Instincts,
not because of the sexiness-
For sure.
but that iconic,
fem, will stop at nothing.
Yes.
Take over, you're like old Hollywood in this show.
It's-
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
Oh, there I am.
It's just such an extraordinary, meaty performance-
Thank you.
And you go for it
and stop at nothing.
Thank you, I really appreciate that.
It felt, it was so fun to do.
I had so much fun being so not fun.
Now I happen to see on your Instagram page,
there's someone very special in your Instagram world,
and in your life.
I know, I know.
You guys dug it up too.
He goes with you everywhere.
Oh, there he is.
(audience laughs)
Will you please explain the history of-
Tino.
Tino!
Tino, yeah.
(audience applauds)
Well, I think my mom must have gotten me this
when I was, I don't know, five or six,
just to do makeup on,
and went dark for years.
Didn't see him.
But then, I was maybe, maybe like 13 or 14,
and my friends and I were in the basement one day
and we dragged him up.
Unearthed
And fresh faced.
Tino.
And we just sort of started taking him around.
And we thought it was really funny
and we'd bring him everywhere and it kinda just stuck
and Tino became a fixture.
And Tino has like, perfor,
like he's posed with Cole Sprouse.
Oh yeah, he hobnobs with the best of them.
Yeah, there he is with Cole.
(audience laughs)
Has Tino ever been-
He's very charismatic.
I mean, that's literally the It boy of the century.
Yeah.
And there's Tino with him.
Has Tino ever been on like a, I don't know,
say, a daytime television show?
Well, no, but there's a first for everything.
Is Tino?
Can he come out?
(audience applauds)
He might be here.
Well, I might have someone for Tino,
if Tino wants to make an appearance.
Oh, do you?
Yeah.
Really?
Really, ready?
Yeah.
One, two, three.
Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
Who's this?
Now I would like to introduce Tino-
Okay.
To, wait,
Tina.
Oh, beautiful.
(audience laughs)
Oh, this is a love story.
I mean, this is a meet cute.
A meet cute!
I love this.
(squeals) Tino And Tina!
This is adorable.
(audience applauds)
Well, maybe they could go on a date after the show?
I think it's...
And start getting their chemistry on.
Yeah, they could hit up a nice little,
they could have a nice little lunch somewhere or a coffee.
Shall we get them ready for their date?
Yeah, let's do it.
Now I can't not ask about
literally one of the most important shows
in television history.
It deserves its own television and radio museum.
"Mad Men".
Oh some chat, yeah.
That thing.
(audience applauds and cheers)
What was,
I mean, did you guys have fun on the set?
Give us a fly on the wall.
Let's see.
Anything on the best show ever made.
I had so much fun.
I love that cast so much.
And I mean, it's crazy, I grew up on it, right?
I was six when I started
and 15 when we wrapped.
Aww, that's cute, aww.
I mean, look at that and now-
I run into John Hamm so much.
(audience applauds)
I was at,
I was at dinner a couple weeks ago with my friends
and John was a couple of tables over,
having a peaceful, nice dinner.
And my friends and I were getting a little rowdy
and we thought it'd be really funny
to start Airdropping people photos in the restaurant,
(Drew laughs raucously)
like really stupid memes and stuff.
And my friend Airdropped a photo and he goes,
"Oh no, I accidentally just
Airdropped something to John Hamm."
(audience laughs)
And John accepted, John accepted the photos.
And then he sort of like,
then they left and we never,
we never had a clarifying moment.
I love that.
I mean,
He's a fun guy.
Everyone wants to have fun.
Play, I'm all about a sense of play.
That's what it is.
It's playful.
I like that.
Do you guys ever talk about a "Mad Men" reunion?
Or like a...
Yeah, we have a group chat
that's pretty popping.
What ha,
what's on it?
I mean, it depends on the day.
It depends on the day.
But once someone writes in the group chat,
everyone is all in and it's like, we're back.
Until that reunion happens-
It's really like we're back.
It is so nice to know-
I know, I know.
That everybody's still talking.
At least we can fantasize about that.
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
If they-
We're all chatting.
If they were to do one, would you play?
Oh, I would I play in a heartbeat.
Any day.
Oh my God.
Let's do a Mad Men reunion.
Let's do a Mad Men reunion!
(audience cheers and applauds)
No, I want to, I would, any day,
if people are hungry for it.
Is it true that you're also like a black-?
Yes.
I'm a black belt in TaeKwonDo.
What?
That's the specific martial art that I'm a black belt in.
Oh my God!
Yeah.
How?
When?
Well, I just,
I signed up for a million things when I was a kid
and that was one of the things that stuck.
I mean, oh my God!
(audience applauds)
I was stressed.
That was my black belt, that was my test for a black belt.
See, I'm wearing a little red belt there.
You're breaking a brick!
I'm breaking a brick.
Break a brick.
They call me brick breaker.
Brick breaker!
Brick breaker.
(audience applauds)
Okay, I am very excited to reveal
Tina to Tino.
Yeah, I've completely
disregarded this because I'm so wrapped in our conversation.
I'm hoping that he likes what he sees
so that maybe we can
(audience laughs)
make them Instagram friends.
I'm ready.
Oh, okay, good.
Okay. Okay.
Oh my God, oh, oh.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Yeah, that actually works.
Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
Wait.
I feel this couple.
They're such a fit.
They're like sexy and cute.
Yes!
This is a hot couple.
New couple alert.
Oh my God, spotted.
Tina and Tino.
(bright theme music)